. Hey, David.
Donald Trump famously said he could shoot
people on Fifth Avenue and not lose any support.
What would it take for Trump's base to abandon
him?
So I've said before.
Would Trump's base abandon him if he insulted
them?
If he said my base is filled with just trash
losers I'd never be caught dead with?
I still think even in that case, a lot of
Trump voters would say he wasn't insulting
me.
He met somebody else.
He didn't mean me when he talked about his
supporters that he hates.
I still don't think that attacking his own
base would get a large number of Trump supporters
to abandon him.
However, I do believe there are people who
would abandon Trump if he loudly came out
in favor of women's right to choose an abortion.
If it's right for them, Donald Trump has maintained
this absurd, unbelievable lie that even though
he was pro-choice his entire life until he
was 68 years old, that when he was in his
late 60s, he met a kid and he liked the kid.
And the kid's mom said, you know, I thought
about having an abortion, but I decided not
to.
Trump claims that was an awakening moment
for him, where he said, I've got to be against
abortion.
It's an obvious lie.
Trump clearly is pro-choice.
It wouldn't be shocking.
To me, if Trump has paid for abortions for
some of his mistresses, it wouldn't surprise
me.
I do think that there's a part of Trump's
base, the evangelical voters, where if Trump
said, hey, you know what?
This right to life stuff of the march for
life that I spoke at.
No, I'm pro-choice.
I do think a lot of those anti-abortion voters
would abandon Donald Trump.
But the reality is, it's not a huge part of
Trump's base.
Evangelicals aren't really his base.
They came to him after mostly supporting.
I think it was Ted Cruz and others in 2016.
They went to Trump when the options were Trump
or Hillary, and they certainly were going
to be voting for Hillary Clinton.
I really don't know what it would take for
Trump's real base to abandon him.
I actually think they would be in denial.
No matter what.
And they would support him if Trump came out
and was loudly anti-gun.
Maybe some of his base would abandon him.
But even then, Trump has said some relatively
anti-gun things.
But then he'll come back and say Joe Biden
will cancel the Second Amendment.
And it's kind of like a choose your own adventure.
I like this thing, Trump said.
So I'm going to believe that that's his real
position.
I really can't think of anything Trump could
do to get the bulk of his real base to abandon
him.
I want to hear from you.
Is there something he could do?
Am I onto something with the gun idea?
Is baby the abortion issue bigger for more
of his base than just the evangelicals that
I'm conceding?
Let me know what you think.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
The bonus show is available to all of our
members and all of our patrons contributing
at the five dollar a month level.
OK, go to join Pacman dot com.
We have a coupon code 20/20 now.
It'll save you 66 percent.
Grab a membership.
You'll get instant access to the bonus show
or make a pledge over at patrie on dot com
slash David Pakman show.
And you will also get instant access otherwise.
That's it for this week.
I'll see you next week.
And remember, not only five new shows next
week, not only five new bonus shows next week,
Tuesday night, September twenty ninth eight,
thirty p.m. Eastern Time, five, thirty p.m.
Pacific.
The first debate between Donald Trump and
Joe Biden.
We will be live on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
I hope to see you there.